[Applaudissements]
vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure que
vous aviez un don au absolument
j'appelais nous cache-t-on avez-vous en
fait je vois les choses je ressens les
choses
en fait je fais des prédictions mais des
prédictions des élections capable de
vous de vous lancer vous avez des
dilatations de visualiser des choses
assez est assez un prénom je jure c'est
très impressionnant
elle a déjà j'ai comme je suis là là
déjà et déjà je su depuis cinq ans
maintenant mais je sens je sens que je
joue trop s'employer d'accord est bien
passé même il faut alors pu nous
expliquer qu est ce que kelly en train
de vous apporter
alors je vais je vais sur ce tableau qui
est un tableau en créer un tout ce qui a
de plus normal voilà ça s'efface voilà
je vais je vais dans un instant j'ai
dans un instant concentrer juste réussi
mais c'est bon on va le faire mais ça va
du stress je me console pas d'accord
mais bon je vais pas besoin de silence
pas tout de suite mais je vais écrire un
non mais quoi il va péter enfin non je
vais écrire je vais
quand j'aurais écrit ce nom j'irai à
pékin le public je ne sais pas encore
qui c'est le hasard chez lazard on y va
alessi et qu'elle va c'est quand tu
aller vers la personne publique
tu vas voir donc il est joli paravent
l'union elle quelqu'un peut-être
d'inconnues sur ce tableau c'est
incroyable ça
[Rires]
thibault qui veut participer bon
monsieur
non pas vous non plus vous allez vous
allez prendre
j'aurais pu vous allez vous allez
prendre cette feuille vous allez écrire
le nom de votre premier petit copain je
vous laisse là je vous laisse là bas
retournez à votre vision est d'accord
madmoizelle com vous avez vous à 100
papa
cynthia marché sur le bureau de
téléphone non non non plus le cas c'est
donc le nom de votre premier petit
copain le mets tout petit 1 c'était
vraiment le premier flirt ah oui ok non
c'est pas pour la future du méchant
michel dessus tu m'as vous allez prendre
jean-michel il faut dix concerts vous
allez plier cette feuille moi je vais me
bander les yeux et démontrer voilà que
vous avez montré lé montrer cette
feuille voilà au public et bien sûr aux
gens qui nous regardent ses bons jours
où la vue est rempli on est d'accord ce
n'est pas d'accord je vais dormir mais
il avait tout ce que je croyais moi euh
donc c'est bon vous avez refusé de
papier oui je ne vois pas ok ça doit
être écrit cynthia cdja c'etait un
c'est donc un garçon oui blond brun
cheveux châtains cheveux châtains et ou
en colonie de vacances en colonies de
vacances d'accord tedeschi la mère la
mère ou sa belle brune est quand même
bien ça a duré combien de temps trois
mois n'a pas duré longtemps
demain c'est quand vous voulez vous des
plus d'oreillettes
non mais je vais c'est pour être que je
veux quoi que je ne comprends pas bien
et qu'il y en a une oreillette et je
pense que j'ai fauté
[Applaudissements]
tout ce que vous me dites là moi je le
sais depuis longtemps je savais que
c'était très loin j'avais senti là ce
pays merveilleux le kenzi je savais que
tout ça je suis en fait je savais tout
mais benji vous l'avez déjà mais je les
écris sur ce tableau en bas sinon vous
mesdames et messieurs
[Applaudissements]
et non cette fois mais génial c'est sur
c'est quoi d'abord assez ensoleillé mais
ça marche avec tous avec des chiffres
des défunts ou pour une autre le soir ça
marche moins bien que l'autopsié que je
choisis au hasard on peut le refaire
on peut choisir eux mêmes leur faire
avec qui vous reste un peu de temps et
on va le faire
nouvelle calédonie et le deuxième prénom
de tous les mecs c'est robin robin